good morning believe nation today's
message is ignore the opinions of others
over to you Paul Thomas Anderson the one
thing I was remember thinking about
trying to make films you always felt
like you got nervous that somebody else
was right was talking to you know who
maybe was in a position of power like
that their opinion somehow was was right
or better than yours and so I mean he
didn't could never stop to think like no
it's just different you just think
differently than I do and that's okay
you know but I'm not wrong in machining
it can get filled with such fear and
it's really easy to get to just get your
heart broken and kind of sort of beaten
that you sort of attempting to make
films I mean you just
it's a miracle any kind of any one of
them gets made you know it's a miracle
and it's a miracle every time I feel
like sometimes every time a scene kind
of gets done and through the birth canal
and done I mean it's never any less of a
miracle or any less difficult it's just
it kind of it just should be no fear you
know I think that's just always remember
kind of being pummeled by fear early on
and feeling like that if I could just
got rid of that fear earlier I this what
about a little bit easier just don't
give up that's kind of the best thing
with it not one ounce of my self-worth
comes from your opinion of me not one
out of my self-worth comes from your
opinion of me I think it's really
important to separate your value as a
human being from what other people think
because if you're constantly being
impacted by other people's impressions
and ideas and opinions then you're never
going to be you because people always
have a direction for your life if you
don't come up with your own life plan I
guarantee the people around you will
create your life plan for you through
their eyes through their lens and they
can't ultimately give you what you need
and so are the most valuable things that
you can learn not just as an
entrepreneur but as a human being is to
separate yourself and your value from
what somebody else thinks about and I
feel disturbed before but I think it's
worth sharing again on this video about
the little man the little man is the
concept in the book and the little man
is the person who just hates little man
is the person who tells you all the
reasons why it's not going to work out
the little man is the person who maybe
took their shot once and they didn't
succeed and so they need to bring
everybody else down because they don't
want to go out and do something amazing
with their life and the only
satisfaction to get was in they can
bring other people down to their level
they want to be above until they need to
crush everyone else around them and they
do it by tearing others down instead of
building up their own thing and the
little man came to me when I was making
one of my biggest videos of all time but
at the start I didn't know what was
going to work out I had this video
around believe it was my first believe
video I just found my one word believe I
wanted to make a video about it and we
made this video that six and a half
minutes long and I showed it to a guy
who was in the industry it's not it's
not just showing it to some high school
friends if they didn't like it it's easy
to reject that opinion and say what you
mean all you're talking about but he was
in the industry he was in the video
industry and he looked at it and he said
no YouTube video should be six minutes
long tell me you actually understand how
the internet works some of the quotes
are in the book and the younger version
of me might have listened to him - a
dream here's some guy who's an expert
who knows what he's talking about maybe
I should listen to his advice and not do
it but when I watched the video myself
it just made me come alive it just made
me so excited I got my blood pumping I
loved it and I couldn't imagine
stripping four-and-a-half minutes out of
it just to make it fit this guy's you
know two minutes timeline and so I
decided you know what forget you I'm
just going to do it and see what happens
and it quickly became the most popular
video on the channel my best video up to
that point had a hundred thousand views
my speciality was took me a year to get
that disputed hit a hundred thousand
views in the first
and now it's over two million views and
so it's great to listen to the opinions
of other people just to get feedback but
at the end of the day it's up to you to
make that decision does it feel right
for you and not to live your life only
according to expectations of other
people and if you don't do what they
want you to do suddenly you feel less
worth because they're attacking thing
you should have done it not one ounce of
my self-worth comes from your opinion of
me embracing that and believing that
will help you build your version of your
life instead of letting other people
dictate your plan so the question today
today is I'm curious I want to hear your
little main story I want to hear a story
of somebody in your life who tried to
hold you back kill you you can't do
something and maybe it worked or maybe
you said no to them I want to hear your
little main story leave in the comments
below and we'll join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Marsha McGuire from waterbirds
calls calm thank you so much Marsha for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me and I hope you're enjoying it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
enterprise high believe nation if you
want to go a little bit deeper into this
topic and learn more and get more
contact I'm adding in some extra bonus
clips that I think you'll enjoy you
don't pay a lot attention to reviews and
those kind of things well you know
you're always affected by opinion but
the more opinions there are of you blow
me more I the less I look at them
because I just can't live my life based
upon what other people think about me so
I can't concern myself too much with
what other people think you know it's
just not healthy I don't think I can I
could continue to do what I do if I was
constantly worrying about what somebody
thought about it how did you ignore all
those naysayers and continue to sort of
blaze the trail of all 90 95 % of all
new ventures fail so if you just bet
against all new venture
the odds are 90% that you're going to be
right 90% of the time but you're going
to miss that 1 out of 110 or 120 chances
to really hit a home run and I wasn't
worried about Tom the naysayers saying
it wasn't going to work I just I just
laughed about it because I knew it was
any works very hard at it is well I
wasn't going to let it fail and even if
you read my book it's right there that I
wasn't going to let it fail and I'm not
going to let all I'm not going to let
humanity fail to get rid of nuclear
weapons and and knob and and and and
handle this energy saying I'm going to
keep fighting til til we start getting
it right
ignore people telling you your idea is
that they may be right but the only way
to know is to actually build it out and
I think the thing that works about
Silicon Valley
this difference in Mexico City or almost
anywhere else in the world is the
default or slump if someone says hey I'm
going to start a start-up here's my idea
the default response is to be excited
and think like oh why might that work
and in most of the rest of the world the
default response when you'd help them on
your idea is to say oh that's not going
to work and this is really toxic for
start-up because you have to believe in
yourself and and the good ideas because
they sound like that ideas are so
fragile and so killable is that you have
to be really careful to insulate
yourself against this